Well,
I,
I think religious communities are
extremely important as ways of
reinforcing individuals,
commitments and identities and that
will,
that continues to be the case and,
and will continue to be the case,
uh,
whether there is a rising tide of
secularism as some argue or a rising
tide of a resurgence of religion
worldwide,
as,
as others argue,
I think depends very much on which
country we look at.
I think if we look at the broader sweep
of human history,
then the,
it's clear the outlier is Europe and
America in so far as it had western
Europe from the enlightenment on and the
United States in so far as it is
followed that pattern and it was only in
perfectly and perfectly followed it for
the rest of human history.
Religion has always been a dimension of
people's finding,
their identity and,
and the affirming values and I think
into a significant degree that is again,
happening worldwide.
Now.
The most visible form of it is Islam in
which it's clear Islam is playing a
major geopolitical role that it hasn't
for,
for some centuries,
but it's not only Islam,
it's also clear that religious,
a resurgence a is evident in other
communities as well.
Uh,
I personally am A.
I'm a Christian who is,
who's Christian identity is,
would be disputed by a great many
Christians.
Uh,
and I guess I could tell you a story
about that.
In,
in 1969,
1970,
I spent a year in Sri Lanka studying
Buddhism and my Buddhist conversation
partners,
uh,
we're convinced that,
that what defined a Christian was that a
Christian believed in God is a being
outside the world who created the world,
number one.
And number two,
that a Christian believed in that every
individual what had an immortal soul.
And when I told him that I didn't
believe either of those propositions,
but considered myself a Christian,
they said,
well,
that's impossible.
You can't be a Christian unless you
believe in a god outside the world who
created the world in an immortal soul.
Uh,
now many Christians would agree those
are very important for defining
Christianity.
So my kind of Buddhist Christianity or
Buddhist influence Christianity is,
is,
uh,
an,
an od,
a combination of affirmations,
but one in which I feel quite
comfortable and in which both some
Christians and some Buddhists would
consider me suspect.